[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
welcome to culture binge the wisecrack
podcast where we get
involved with all things cultural
zeitgeist related i am michael
joined by wisecrack overload
extraordinary overload i meant overlord
[ __ ] i'm gonna say that again i'm
michael
joined by wisecrack a man at the top
alec how are you doing today alec i'm
great i forgot to turn on my light i'm
gonna do that
wow and joined by the woman
with a new microphone and lots to say
serbia serbie how are you hi i'm will
i'm how are you
great it's good to hear you loud and
clear excited to be here
um a lot of great stuff to talk about
today i'm truly i'm always excited but
today is topic list it's just fantastic
so we're going to talk about cult
leaders maybe give you some advice if
that's something you're interested in
getting involved with
we're going to talk about dating during
covit this is going to be very
interesting and of course we would love
to hear what anyone has to say about
this and then we'll talk about how
boomer parents created millennial
burnout so uh for anyone who wants to
blame your problems on your parents
hopefully we can give you some fuel to
do that but for the time being
let's get started with some slaps and
chaps so
serbia let's get started with you what
are your slabs and chats this time
around
so what slaps is greg edwards slaps uh
for those of you who don't know greg
edwards is the comedian who plays
sparky sweets phd and wisecracks thug
notes
um i just learned that uh greg is an
artist
and he's really talented i looked at his
website and
really great stuff uh it's greg
edwardsart.com
um he has a black flag series that he
just came out with it's
so great i actually once purchased uh
it used to be on that wall but i think
we moved it but he has uh
these cool they're like artists like
basquiat
or like rappers like jay-z um
superimposed over like uh red line maps
of like the cities they grew up in red
lining
oh yeah uh like a mortgage policy where
they wouldn't give mortgages to like
black people outside of specific areas
to enforce
segregation and stuff like that um it's
cool stuff
yeah really great so greg edwardsart.com
check it out
um what chaps
everything has trapped last couple weeks
have been kind of hard
so just felt kind of blue
well we're not down or not i'm sorry no
it's okay but we're sorry and we know
that
everyone in the culture bench family is
sorry and we hope things start turning
around because you deserve
a life full of all slaps no chats thank
you
yes it's true um alec how about you slap
some chaps
uh the vow slaps i'm not gonna say
anymore it's my topic so i'm not gonna
cheat but what chaps is that in
seven ish days i won't get to send your
dumb memes and be like hey man can we
make a video about this
and that makes me sad you're gonna have
to send yourself dumb memes to say hey
man can we make a video about it really
i'm gonna send you dumb memes and
i'm gonna say can we make a video about
this and be like i don't know man you
get to decide that [ __ ] and i'll be like
why aren't you
jared i think you're being too
idealistic i think now you're the person
who's gonna shoot down the ideas and
dreams
of people like myself who send you
things they can make a video of this and
you just say
no like twister but also i want someone
to shoot down my dreams
everyone needs someone to shoot down
their dreams because lots of dreams are
dumb everyone
psa i'll shoot them down wow this is
we're really starting off on a positive
note all your dreams are dumb um
okay well those those are good slaps and
jabs um
so my slap will be that the american
ninja warrior came back i have talked
about it before
um i mentioned this but they're doing a
bubble season it's in st louis
all the athletes are in a contained
space it's incredible just like the nba
they've managed to capture
the thrill and drama of america's you
know greatest future pastime without
losing anything if you don't already
watch it
nbc monday nights it's great just record
it so you can fast forward through some
of the personal interest stuff but it's
fantastic
um chaps less sad than the past two
i'm hitting a bit of a recipe dead end
i've been cooking you know
every day sometimes two meals a day for
over six months now
and i've started to get sick of recipes
that i'm like cycling back through
so this week i realized that i did order
a new cookbook
but i'm lacking inspiration so if anyone
knows good recipes or has ideas let me
know
i've been making a lot of thai food
lately i love thai food
like curry have you made like green
yellow or red any of the curry's
name of color i've made the card
have you done pad thai i have made pad
thai yeah oh wow you've gone through
everything
you know sometimes i struggle with tai
though because i
think to myself i could make tie tonight
or
because i live a mile and a half from
thai town i could just go pick up really
good thai food
yeah and it makes me talk about
triangulation yes
oh no no no um i don't live anywhere
near any neighborhood that's called thai
town i live in nevada
nevada is where i live okay so
well hold on my my slaps was almost an
eggplant tour that i made this week you
should fry some eggplant
put it on like a good uh like nice bun i
did brioche which is not the
traditional torta put some avocado put
some sauce some roasted red pepper
it'll be real good it sounds delicious i
had a
this eggplant al pastor thing at a
restaurant in chicago a year ago that i
liked a lot was a good use of eggplant
mexican food
but sorry for making anyone hungry who's
listening to this but if you're in the
chat let us know what you're making or
what you feel like making it what we
should make
so the first thing we're going to talk
about today is cults
and the vow and all the good that you
can find through
joining up with some like-minded people
and paying money to be involved so
alec the ball is in your court so
uh hbo's vow maybe you haven't seen it
it's about a
multi-level marketing company called
nexium that's spelled nxivm
because and they've been around for 20
years so they were chopping off letters
and making [ __ ] weird before it was
officially cool to do so
um what do you what do you two know
about it i think you know michael serbi
do you know about
nexium yeah i think i talked about it
before
um it was like a they do like the it's
like the sex cult with the branding
on the bodies yeah and uh serbia serbia
nailed it so nexium
multi-level marketing they run an
executive success program it's uh
kind of like trump university met
herbalife you know
it's mixing like these classes about how
to succeed in life with
you know an actual pyramid scheme uh but
most notably as serbie mentioned
a part of nexium basically became an
instrument for keith reinier
keith renery the founder to create a sex
cult um people would be branded with his
initials
uh it was he was running it with this
actress named allison mack who was on
wilford which is a great show by the way
she was also on smallville i think
i forgot she was on that on wilfred oh
my god yeah i need to finish wilfred i
never did but it was very good
um so as i mentioned all documented in
the vow on hbo
everyone should go check it out it's
very good if you have access to hbo
um but what i actually want to talk
about here
is uh keith renery you know
in the documentary they really talk
about how he's like the smartest man on
earth
uh apparently he's in the guinness book
of world records for like take
scott scoring really hard scoring really
high on this unsupervised test that has
since come
under a lot of scrutiny um and
you know still somehow ended up in
against book of world records for it
but he uh really likes to wax poetic and
philosophical about things also a lot of
what he does seems like
kind of like therapy with different
words and uh
you know between like psychology and the
philosophy i was like i need to
because i'm a weirdo i wasn't just like
wow this guy is a weird sex cult leader
i was like oh
i wonder like what his philosophy is
like um and i haven't done
dug too much in but there's some really
great moments in there like uh
one thing that really struck me is he's
talking to someone in i think in his sex
cult
uh about like his definition of hell and
uh that definition of hell is that when
you die you meet the version of yourself
you could have been
um and i mentioned this to to michael
off the podcast
but it's like a weird rhetorical spin on
like nietzsche's a more fatty like it's
an idea that i'm like oh that's that's
kind of like not
the worst idea like sure it's poetic and
whatever but it's not that different
from
nietzsche who believe that you should
live a life and look back at all your
choices and be able to sort of affirm
them
but anyway the thing that really gets me
is kind of uh something i see in a lot
of places besides
places like nexium uh and the the sex
cult
branch of it um but like a weird
weaponization of stoicism
and also like mindfulness and so to sort
of
set this up a little bit stoicism
ancient greek philosophy
um there was one notable stoic there
were many uh this
guy named epictitus epictetus um was
born a slave
and he kind of came out of the whole
experience with the stoic philosophy
that is probably
many of you are not strangers to
basically the ability to distinguish
between the things that you can and
can't control right like i can control
my reaction to something i can control
my mood
i can control my desires but i can't
control what other people are doing
i can't control my external
circumstances in his case he literally
could not control that he was a slave
um and so i think a lot of self-help
sort of whether they're
reading about epictetus or not they're
really sort of appropriating this idea
as a vehicle for change and you know
stoicism is fine but
again i think it's sort of stretched out
in a way and on the other side of things
there's
mindfulness which a very similar thing
you know if you're stressed if you're
chronically stressed
you know really be mindful of your
thoughts and feelings those are the
things you can control not out
not outside of them and so uh rainier
uses this for all kinds of bonkers [ __ ]
and just next him at large and uh
listening to
uh the dream is a wonderful podcast that
has a whole season about mlms and this
sort of thing also comes up there
but it's like if you're not recruiting
enough people into his cult
oh you know you can't change what other
people are doing only like focus on
yourself you know all you can do
is be the best version of yourself so if
you're not recruiting people in this
cult like really it's your fault
um of course there's other factors in
there that he doesn't want you to think
about like there's lots of press about
how he had sex slaves or he ran another
multi-level marketing
firm and had to pay a 40 000 fine uh
because it was alleged to be a pyramid
scheme
um when it becomes sex cult time in the
vow
the same sort of thing comes up where
these people are living this very like
aesthetic lifestyle
where they're restricting their calorie
intake to get skinnier so
they can be more appealing to him but
also like they set goals for themselves
you know they don't get into physics but
maybe it's not eating junk food or not
checking instagram
but it's all about like the self mastery
kind of in the stoic tradition
that's like i need to be the master of
my
own self via being a slave to somebody
else
and so the obviously weaponization of
this comes into
oh if i'm branding you the only thing
you can control like pain is an illusion
like in the buddhist sense the only
thing you can control is your reaction
to it
um and so i think it's really
interesting not only because keith
renery is like misusing these or not not
even misusing them sort of weaponizing
these concepts
but i think it's a lot of things we've
talked about mindfulness how it's sort
of weaponized to say like
hey don't worry about the workload we're
putting on you all you can control
is your reaction to it so why don't you
do this meditation exercise instead of
asking for a raise sort of stuff
um so i don't know uh burns i i believe
you watched it
uh what do you and serbia also what do
you think about this
i mean i've watched it almost every
episode i think twice now except the
last one because i had to
watch it with someone who was slacking
but i'm nice like that
um i mean one of the weirdest things
about watching the vow is the first
episode
part of the way through i was like i get
this yeah um
especially when they get into this idea
of limiting beliefs this thing where
like
things that we can't do in life or
things we struggle with
come down to limiting beliefs we have
that constrain
our like view of ourselves and our
potentials and i was like oh
totally i get that if i was in a room
where someone taught me that i would
think that is that is cool
um well the other thing though is like
that uh
that is like a thing you learn in
cognitive behavioral therapy and so like
they put like weird terms on these
things that are like evidence-based
sorry
go ahead yeah and it was interesting to
learn that nancy salzman
um who we call what is she the rector uh
guard and proctor yeah um so this is the
the educational director of sorts of the
organization
um nancy's background is a hypnotist so
she has brought in
mind control techniques basically to
these people but i think that the doc
does a good job of slowly
unfolding how rational people could get
involved
in these things and i think that's
really important because a lot of docs
or explorations of cults are just like
oh these idiots that had
issues at home who were runaways or
whatever got sucked into this
evil thing and in the vow you see a lot
of people where you're like wow
she was in star wars movies why would
why would this person need to
get sucked up into this uh but then the
thing you know i
i can't stop thinking about as i watch
it
is it's a lot a lot of the people that
got drawn into next game were like
actors and performers
and it seems like they initially get
pulled in to help them with their craft
but then they stop doing their craft
so i like i love how colts do this thing
where like i sign up for
self-improvement so i can do better at
auditions and booking roles
but what self-improvement looks like is
giving up my career altogether
to help other people learn how to
self-improve well that's the pyramid
scheme
thing yeah like the thing about pyramid
schemes with like physical products
say it's like vitamins is that there's
no real external market for it there's
not
the difference between a pyramid scheme
and real business is like oh i'm gonna
sell you these vitamins and you're a
regular consumer of vitamins taking a
regular amount of vitamins
becomes a pyramid scheme when your main
consumer is
other people buying vitamins to sell
them and so that's what i think
yeah but yeah there is no external or
the external market of people
actual actors who are going to use these
skills is like very very limited really
like
the best way to use it is to recruit
more people to
recruit more people to take this
executive class well and i'll just yeah
i'll end with this like i think that's
what's so
brilliant about nexium it's obviously
bad sex cult branding not good but the
brilliance of it as a model is
what they're selling is kind of like a
spiritual practice so i think
i think a lot of people can see through
no um shannon i'm not gonna buy your
dumb vitamins
but when you're offering like a way of
life
and there's the guy um is it chippy
what's his name oh his name is
nip nippy nip nippy yeah so nippy at one
point
um a a character in the show talks about
how he wanted to make the world a better
place and he says something like well if
you want to be a person that makes the
world better
you're going to get involved in politics
like no those are corrupt systems what
do
you
go to religion a thing that we've seen
how corrupt that can be
so this idea that it appeals to people
who want to self-improve
in a pseudo-philosophical religious way
it offers that space and i think that's
the sort of sick genius
of of the nexium cult serving
so i i
feel very uncomfortable with colts at
baseline but also because i have family
members who are in a cult
oh yeah and you know this
yeah and so um it's the same sort of
thing like it starts out like
they make it seem like oh it's like a
social thing like we're all just gonna
get together and when you're retired and
you have nothing really to do
it seems like okay yeah that's nice like
hang out with some other old people um
and then it slowly turns into oh well
you should like donate some money
and then you should donate some more
money and more money
and then it's oh well you should have
your family come
um and now it's gotten to the point
where
like cult meetings happen to take place
on every major holiday
and it's like well if you don't come
then like you need to be working on
yourself and if somebody's not
supporting you then they're the problem
and they don't want you to be the best
you can be
um so it's really hard and so my mom
looked into it
and was trying to reason with these
family members
and she was like the worst thing is
the cult has so my mom has a background
in psychology
and so she's like this cult has like
elements of like cbt and mindfulness and
like all the same things so she's like
of course they feel
good after they go to these like cult
meetings she's like they're basically
having like psychological interventions
and she's like just go to therapy like
if you need help and you want to feel
good like
you just need a therapist um
yeah i don't know it's hard it's sad and
from like
watching your family go through that
it's you feel powerless
especially when there's money at stake
too because
you wonder like well what are you saying
to like get
their money and like what's going on in
the background yeah and
i think one really sort of interesting
component
is that i probably mentioned this before
because i i think about this
quite a lot but dave graber r.i.p in
[ __ ] jobs talk about
there's like a systemic uh lack of
agency
in our in our society because we many of
us work [ __ ] jobs who don't get to
do much
but psychologically as humans we have
like a joy of being the cause which is
like you
as a toddler learn that you know if i
knock this thing over a table it'll
break and like i did that that's [ __ ]
rad and like that
kind of can explain you know sort of a
sense of meaning in our lives we want to
feel
responsible for things that we did them
and a lot of the rhetoric you hear
in nexium is about changing the world
that's what you're saying about nippy
like he wants to change the world he
wants to be a force for good
but philosophical but also it like puts
in all these little steps for you
for you to sort of get that high of
feeling accomplished whether it's like
getting your next sash
your new color you know it's very sort
of concrete achievable goals that don't
exist a lot of people's jobs like you
can work your ass off for
three years and maybe you won't get a
raise but like if i recruit this many
people and take this many classes like i
know i will get to the next level and
get this [ __ ] sash
um and so like i get it and at the same
time the the dream talks about this too
like
mlms in general also appeal to this
because um
mlms are often done by like a lot of
women women who like aren't given
you know economic opportunities outside
the home or economic
opportunities aren't available to them
basically there's just like a lot of
housewives
who feel unfulfilled because they're not
really they're not being the cause or
whatever and so
to become an entrepreneur to become a
business leader it's just like an easy
recipe for people to get sucked into
these horrible horrible things
yeah and it does i saw someone i quickly
looked at the chat and i saw someone
bring up improv classes
but when i when i watched the balance of
yeah i do think about like improv
classes and like crossfit
and these things we do have that are
more like
culturally appropriate and we don't
think of as cults
that do have similar dynamics whether
it's like in crossfit you get to a
certain level to become a trainer i know
a lot of you know
improv and comedy theaters and like
acting schools it's like you get to this
level
and this level and you get this perk at
this level but the whole way you're just
giving more and more money
so i think the the vow stuff and nexium
is scary
what might be scarier too sometimes is
how the mlm logic trickles into things
that are considered more normative and i
would say
you know you brought up jobs alec i
think in general that logic doesn't play
into jobs
but having uh recently read a book about
silicon valley culture
and you definitely see some of it there
um the sort of
psych the psychology the psychological
elements of cults being used to enforce
this like
did your job is your life and your
purpose culture yeah
i forgot if it was jeff bezos but
something like someone raised something
about work-life balance and they're like
listen if you can't work
you know 18 hours a day like that's on
you you don't belong here
and i think it's very much like
something keith renery would say sorry
sir we go ahead
so i work i work in the tech industry in
startups and that's very much like it
does feel like a cult
a lot of times and one prevailing
thought is
like well
our culture is our culture and if you
can't adapt to it then it'll just
weed out the weak yeah and so
the the awful thing about that is
there's so much pressure because you're
like well i have to
go to the after work event or i have to
work on the weekends or i have to do
this i have to do that because if i
don't then
i'm not the one that gets the promotion
or i'm not the one that gets moved up
um it does feel like a cult and when i
always find a new job i always
ask a lot of questions about the culture
because
that is the most important thing like
cults come in all forms and
it's like working at a job you slow you
stop thinking about it as a cult
you start to think about it it's like
well this is just the culture and i need
to adapt and these are our values
um yeah the the volleyball and stuff in
the vow
really reminded me of and i know i've
said this before too i i was an r.a in
college but r.a training was all about
like building community and being an r
is not a cult but like
every time i see a group of adults
playing volleyball or like doing team
building exercises i think about that
and now i will forever think about like
keith rainier building a sex cult
um but same thing like you know uh we've
never really done this at wisecrack but
you know you go to some like company
retreat to build it and i'm not saying
that's cultish but i think
there's a uncanniness that bothers me
most definitely um and i think you know
the main takeaway from all this is any
organization that
requires you to play volleyball from 12
a.m to
7 a.m is not your friend um so now that
we know how to avoid cults
um and we don't find community there i
think we might need to talk about how we
can find community and the loving
embrace
of another um so one of the we've talked
a lot about
covid and how it's affected our culture
we haven't really talked about dating
much yet so serbia
um get us into the particular problems
and possibilities of dating during covet
yes so lock down dating i've been
talking to a few friends
who are going on dates during this
pandemic and it's
so interesting um they're meeting at
parks and other public spaces
or open spaces and one of my friends
made an interesting observation she said
that
by wearing a mask and being and having
some physical distance
from her dates it makes her anticipate
seeing the guys more and she's really
excited about like a first kiss
or when she sees the guy without a mask
she's sort of like oh wow
she's like these little things feel so
thrilling um
and after hearing these experiences i've
started to reflect on
my experience with online dating that i
did years and years ago
and i always felt like it was so
impersonal and it was just a series of
swipes
and judgments were made in a flash
and it's so easy to get caught up in how
someone looks or
um what their job is or how funny their
bio is
and you stop really seeing the person
and you just start to see like
what what it like what are the little
facts about them
um and through conversations with
with others who have done online dating
i realized that
people felt like there were so many
options available and
it was hard to settle on one person
because their thought was like oh well
there could be a better match tomorrow
or maybe if i just
swiped a little bit more then i could
find someone who's smarter or prettier
or funnier
um so my experience with online dating
was horrible and it felt like
every guy i went out with either wanted
to like
pass the time like just chatting on the
app because they were bored
or they wanted to hook up right away and
they didn't want anything serious so
there seemed to be like this rush like a
rush
to me a rush to kiss a rush to hook up
and i hated that i wanted things to slow
down
and so now with the pandemic i've heard
that things are slowing way down
because people are more selective with
who they meet in person and they're
taking their time getting to know
others over text or phone call or zoom
first
and they've even slowed down with
physical intimacy because they don't
want to catch covert
and one guy i spoke to said that he
was dating a girl for a month before
they kissed
and he's like i hadn't haven't waited a
month before kissing someone since high
school
so he said that it felt kind of special
like there was it felt more meaningful
to him
um and the kiss felt more intense to him
so
i'm wondering whether the pandemic will
change the dating landscape in the same
way that apps and websites did
a couple decades ago like will we start
to see relationships
have a slower burn and involve people
taking their time getting to know each
other
and i'm curious because it feels like
the sort of thing that everybody's going
through
all at the same time so maybe we might
start to value different things
um and not look i mean i think we'll
still look at looks and things like that
but
that maybe relationships might be
stronger because there was
more more of an emphasis on getting to
know each other before you
you do other things so i know both of
you are in relationships and i
i know i think one of you hasn't done
online dating
but i'm curious about your thoughts i
think that guy well can i ask one
question of clarification i just don't
know if that your friends got into this
when they are covered distance dating
before
the kiss are they getting like tested or
at this point are you just like
[ __ ] it we've been safe why not so a
couple of them do insist on getting a
kova test done
um and a few of them were like well if
if we've talked about it and they're
you know working from home and not doing
anything then we'll just
kiss each other um but they're like it
really depends on the person and if i
feel like there's a lot of um
trust and respect there i can't imagine
kissing a string i mean even if i've
known them for a while and like
even like i've i've seen
my family in person once outside i don't
even hug them and so like to [ __ ]
kiss
to like swap saliva fluid with like a
person i've known for a month like
and i'm not i'm not hating on it i'm not
like i get it
people need to do these things but it
scares me i don't like it
yeah i definitely couldn't do it i i've
i think i've gone from being what i
thought was
normative coveted conscious but i feel
like a lot of other people around me
have chilled out so now i look more
extreme by comparison
but if i was single i don't know i might
like be on dating apps
because i'd be lonely and i might want
to like meet people and talk to them
but i can't see me wanting to do
anything more than like maybe go on some
walks with masks
and kind of like take it a little bit
easy in that way
um but i get it like one of my best
friends uh is currently
if i can speak about them um covet
dating and navigating that and i you
know
i feel for them um but it just sounds
weird and i have heard about like the
flip side of this too of like coveted
sex hookups so i've seen people talk
about this on twitter
of people just like straight up hooking
up and like wearing masks as they have
sex
i even saw someone talking about they
were going to meet a hookup like in
someone's backyard so they could like
bang it out on a deck
so it would be safer i like i guess
shouts
to be for being safe there yeah well i
wonder one thing serbia in relation to
what you said about this changing
dating culture do we think that
if you know if this ever ends knock on
wood
do we think this could lead back to
people wanting
more like organic in-person dating will
this create more of a desire
to get back to like meeting people out
and meeting people through friends and
being more organic or is this going to
push us
even more into dating as matrix-esque
activity
i think it might be a push to meet more
organically because
our whole lives are online now a lot of
people work from home we order our
groceries online we do everything online
our doctor's appointments are online
so i think like for me the last thing i
want to do is do another thing online
um so i think people might be more
interested in
going out and like doing things and
trying to meet people that way
i i do know serbia has to grab her
charger but there is one comment that i
want to address that says alec is weird
no offense no offense taken i'm a weird
dude
uh dude what do these millennials not
have casual safe sex
uh i will just say that i'm terrified
of all people uh their germs and other
things
at bodily fluids and so i'm just like uh
isn't there a word for this like a wife
guy no yeah you're you're a white guy
yeah no yeah i've been in a relationship
for
eight or nine or ten years i don't
[ __ ] know but like
yeah if i had to meet strangers on the
internet and then like proceed to figure
out like how to ho there'd just be a lot
of hurdles to get over versus like oh i
i met this person in college and we've
known each other for a couple months
and now are dating um but i'm saying i'm
i'm not a freak like alec i used to be a
normal person that met people and
and had consensual sex or whatever it
might be i've just been in a
relationship
for a while so i'm not on dating apps
because
we're stuck in the same apartment and if
my partner looked over and saw me on a
dating app things would get very
uncomfortable
yeah although once i did as a bit
during dinner with my partner and
friends make a dating app account and
started getting matches because they
thought i was kidding
and then i turned my phone over and
showed my matches and and it made the
dinner awkward
and we had to have a talk afterwards so
uh
you know be careful universal studios
and don't sign up for a dating app as a
bit
in front of your partner but serbia back
to you and your
your powered up computer but no i think
the point you make about the change back
to organic culture is interesting
because i think about how
five months ago it was like hey guys
let's have zoom happy hour and now like
i would rather slam my [ __ ] foot in a
door than do another
goddamn zoom hangout and like at this
point i'm just like i'll wait a year
and see you in person at this point then
do more zoom socialization because it
does feel kind of hollow
so yeah i wonder if if like that dating
is going to become this thing we
do more in person than we have been i i
also just wonder
uh i think i've no more
like hookup culture's fine i have no
problems with that people can you know
do whatever they want
but i do feel like uh this is one of
those things that might like ebb and
flow
like there will be a sort of reaction to
it where people are like i'm sick of
this like i
would rather sort of to what service
saying like there's something nice about
knowing someone for a month and then
waiting to kiss them
uh again no moral judgments about either
but i feel like both
cultures have their pros and cons one
lots of sex the other one like getting
to know people
so i i'm very excited about this whole
like not so i'm not dating and i don't
plan to anytime soon but i'm very
excited about this like taking
taking time to get to know people
because i i've always found it very
strange like wanting to sleep with
someone like
like i just couldn't do it sleeping with
somebody i've only known for like
a week or something it just feels so
personal or like kissing them
and so i got really good at like this
ninja dodge like where guys are trying
to hug me but like go in for the kiss
and i'd be like oh [ __ ] no
oh no it was kind of like a like a dab
but without dabbing you know like the
dab motion of your body
um it's very attractive and
i um i like i like the idea of being
like no i don't i don't want to do
anything also i always
insist on an std test before sleeping
with somebody
um and so now i get to insist on a covid
and an stp test
nice nice nice i don't that's not
unreasonable if you're in a relationship
um test them up guys uh
yeah and i do and this is just like
we'll get into this later in the show
but if you're currently covet dating we
would love to hear about it
you can get in touch with us
cultureringwisecrack.com tell us all
about it
we'll keep it anonymous really get into
it we want to hear
yeah i think it's time to talk about how
boomers are in the world is that what
we're talking about
yeah a little bit so um okay so there's
i'll start with this there's a book that
came out and i think it literally came
out yesterday or the day before because
i had it pre-ordered and my local
bookstore emailed me and said
it's time what kind of psycho pre-orders
books first of all
i don't know maybe a psycho trying to
support his local independent bookstore
during a pandemic
um i don't know maybe that but yeah alec
bezos over here
jesus christ um but enough about me
being a nerd with books um
but this author um anne helen peterson
has a book that just came out it's
called can't even
how millennials became the burnout
generation and she's doing a lot of
interviews there's a lot of articles
about the book
coming out this week um and there's one
in particular that
dropped in the atlantic uh just to use
cool terms to talk about atlantic
articles
it's called how boomer parenting fueled
millennial burnout
and it's pretty interesting and it sucks
to read if you're someone that
is a millennial and grew up with boomer
parents and
the so i think two chapters of the book
deal with parenting on one side
what how millennials were parented and
on the other side how millennials
are parenting um to skip to the
conclusion of it
millennials are parenting real badly
because they're just taking what their
parents did to them and accelerating it
which is horrifying
but she describes in this interview
two problems to millennial parenting
sorry the way millennials were parented
one she says
is the first is conceiving of children
as many
adults trying to cultivate behaviors
postures and skills that are associated
with adults like being able to carry on
conversations with adults or advocating
for themselves when they feel something
is unfair
so you know one thing she thinks boomers
did is try to like you know make kids
mini adults
the second is thinking of childhood as a
means to an
end and that end of course is getting
into a good college and i don't know
about you all but i know like
from a very young age i was aware that
there was a thing called college
and that every part of my life was
somehow aimed
at this thing called college and all i
knew about college is what i saw from
saved by the velvet college years
so it did seem kind of fun at that point
um
now the sort of like larger uh sort of
explanation she gay
she gives for boomer parenting is
actually um
economic anxiety so this idea that
in the 70s and 80s things went well for
a lot of boomer parents and they were
making money
but as things started to kind of turn
down a little bit at the tail end of the
boomer generation
parents were so anxious about their
children not achieving a level of
success or
wealth that they had that they felt like
they needed to go
real ham basically to do this um
now a lot of what goes on in her
research and book and i think this
author is really interesting as well
maybe on a personal level because this
is someone that went and did a like phd
in cultural studies
um wanted to be an academic got burned
out on the academic job market
started writing for internet
publications and then wrote this book
about millennial burnout so i love the
academia to internet pipeline um the
michael burns pipeline
yeah the final lawrence pipeline and
then she like but she did something that
i still haven't done which is moved to
montana with her dogs which is the dream
to live in montana with dogs
and just hang out um someone in montana
build a compound for wisecrack
okay so uh last thing i'll say from this
so she brings up this idea
and here's a quote from the author and
helen peterson says one of the saddest
things i heard when talking to many
millennials
is that when they reach a point of
exhaustion with work lift their heads up
and look around them they're like
what else is there do i have a
personality do i know what i like
there's no there there other than their
ability to work
and i think that's really difficult so
basic just
boomers full of economic anxiety
obsessed with their children
being safe in economic terms um project
mini adulthood and all this pressure
onto kids the kids grow up
and for lack of a better term they have
zero chill they can't relax
and they're burned out all the [ __ ]
time and you know if you want to look up
her
original article she wrote it was a
buzzfeed piece uh that was called
something like millennials in the
burnout generation
i sent it to a good friend this morning
and he got part of the way through
before he said he started having like an
anxiety attack
so be careful if you read that um but i
know
what do you all think i don't want to
you know ask anyone to be too
forthcoming in their own anecdotes from
childhood but like
do we think or did we have experiences
in which
we think the boomers did this to us
survey so i i grew up knowing about
college and knowing that i
had to go to college um and then when i
was in college my mom's
i really wish i hadn't pushed you to go
to college because maybe that wasn't
what was right for you um and so now we
have
pretty extensive conversations about
that like how
she grew up thinking about education
about education i think it could be a
cultural thing as well like in the
indian culture there's a great emphasis
on education
um but she and i were saying that when i
have kids i'm not going to make
college the only option for them like i
want them to know that they can do other
things
if that's what's right for them because
maybe a formal
like college experience isn't what they
need but maybe they want to go to art
school or maybe they don't want to go to
school and they just want to start
working or start their own business or
i don't know bum around europe for a
couple years um
so i do think that like college was good
for me
i don't think that i would have gone to
college right when i was 18.
um i probably would have taken a couple
years off
and like traveled or worked or something
and then gone to school afterwards
i am burnt out but not because of the
way i was raised i think it's more just
a personality thing and then also just
the places i've chosen to work
encourage burnout yeah
i was not i was growing up with this
like
it wasn't even a pressure it was just
like people go to college
uh if you don't go to college that's
that's not something people do or like
uh and to sense i think there is uh not
that i think this is a good thing but
there's a certain
there's a certain sense of fairness that
in that
the way our economy is set up right now
and it's probably bad is for any
[ __ ] job you need a college degree
which is not actually true but that's
hiring so
basically unless you want to work in a
trade which to be honest make much more
money
and probably a lot more fulfilling than
like oh sort of like
i'm a marketing assistant at some ad
agency
um you know it's college or trade uh
and so but i never had the like you need
to get into harvard you need to go that
uh i did go to a college that was well
known for being
where people went to if they got
rejected from nyu so i know lots of
people like that
um but
yeah i think i'm weird i don't think
there was that sort of
pressure there for me but i think i did
have sort of
grand ambitions but no idea how to
realize them like nobody at one time i
was like i want to be an astrophysicist
and like i had no idea what that meant
like i mean i knew that space was cool
and i like science classes but no one
was like okay well you have to get a phd
and then you do this and that and that
that there was no sense of that but uh i
think on the the burnout
for me this is maybe not helpful to a
lot of people listening like i don't
necessarily feel burned out by my career
but if there is a source of burnout
it is the youtube algorithm and i will
leave it at that
um i have to say the most important
revelation of this podcast thus far alec
is that i too wanted to be an
astrophysicist when i was young and i
too had no one to show me how and i
was obsessed with it i think i like
emailed some professor at uchicago when
i was like
12 and had my first email address to be
like how can i become an astronaut for
those songs
um but no i think we seem to all have
something in common where maybe we
didn't have the traditional like
boomer parenting vibe because and this
isn't like a dark thing it just is what
it is like i didn't have like
particularly
good or involved parents so i didn't
have
a lot of like pressure from them but i
still had
general societal pressure stuff that was
talked about in school stuff that you
saw
and i think even if you don't have
parents pushing you to do that
it's culturally normative like you said
it's like well what do you do
when you finish high school you go to
college and i think often the narrative
when you're young is if you don't go to
college
your life is over you're screwed and
there was a point where um
when i was finishing high school i
didn't know if i want to go to college i
was
playing music in some bands and i really
liked it
yeah and i was like oh maybe rather than
go to college and commit all that money
right now
i'll take some classes at like a
community college that cost
almost nothing play music and just like
see how it goes for a couple years and i
look back like i think that would have
been a totally reasonable option
it would have cost less money in the
long run um
i just there's nothing wrong there but
to my parents and then people i brought
that up to
you would have thought i said to them
like yeah i met this guy named keith
renery online he bought me a bus ticket
to
albany i'm psyched about it like and i
think that
yeah i think we we've created a culture
that
is is sort of presupposing an economic
paradigm that might not exist
anymore which is that a certain version
of like
reagan-era successful capitalism or
something
and i think that is problematic and i
think one of the bummer parts about
you know the interview that inspired
talking about this and
uh peterson's book as a whole is there's
not a lot of solutions because whenever
she's pressed on that it's basically
like well
the system is what the system is it's
very hard
to opt out of it um and some of her only
hope was seeing some gen z people
rebel against it and sort of see through
the [ __ ] of a lot of this stuff
yeah um i think that
is very true uh i think we do need to
move on to the mailbag though
because i know let's get into the
mailbag i love the mailbag it's my
favorite place um
so before we get into it just a quick
reminder we love to hear from you more
than anything
about whatever and i think especially
this time too if you've been in a cult
let us know if you're dating during
covet let us know if you feel burned out
let us know
and in all of those cases you can remain
anonymous if you want um
so hit us up at culture binge wisecrack
dot co no
m um culture of ninja wisecrack.com or
call us at 213 534 8807 that is
213-534-8807
alec what do we got this time we've got
a great voicemail that i've specifically
instructed neither of you to listen to
and so yes i'm enjoying let's let's
let's play that
all right i'm telling about your
culture binge on only fans and the
controversies around it but not
specifically about bella thorne messing
it up
the main issue for me and it touches on
the idea of legalizing broader sex work
it really just circles around buttholes
i mean have you ever been on twitter
discord
read it it's insane the amount of just
random buttholes with only fans links
you'll find
if you look up any trending tag and for
sale far enough it's just buttholes
right at new posts buttholes you can't
escape them i feel like vin diesel and
pitch black
i like the flare and they all recoil
backwards in fact only fans have ruined
them for me completely
imagine that you're me you're a good
person you hate your job
you socially distance you wash your
hands anything oh well i'm going to
treat myself i'm going to go look at
butts
on the internet not now now i think to
myself i want to check twitter for a
little bit
i hope i don't see a flurry of anuses
and sure enough i do
i saw today while looking up 911
remembrance posts and only found the
girls doing people for nine dollars and
11 cents
to donate unfortunately to widows or
something so they've tainted
pains for me now i will really feel it
must feel when the next patient comes in
every week every week the only thing
that i don't like about
this is i did get like um a weird mean
dm from someone that watches wisecrack
stuff saying that like
i can't talk out of my butthole so i
hope it wasn't this person because the
person who sent me the
cyberbully dm was a dick and this person
sounds incredible so i hope
you're not the same that's amazing
yeah thank you ron uh that was amazing
that was that was
wonderful i mean maybe in the philosophy
of keith ranieri you're the problem not
the buttholes you can't control the
buttholes you can only control your
reaction to them why don't we do a deep
em
of your version of balls he just wants
to do things in his life and there's
buttholes at every which corner that's
that's rough all right uh we've got
two emails to go into again it's culture
binge at wisecrack.com
serbia if you need to leave i understand
we love you very dearly yes
yes if you don't hear serbia's voice
anymore it's not because uh we killed
her it's because she had to go do her
important job
yes
she's the quality assurance person for
only fans
butthole tags it's best job ever uh
anyone else is a great meme cat
buttholes i'll just leave it at that
i don't know i'm mad that i know what
that is now okay well we got emails
all right we got an email from anthony
uh long time listener and watcher of
your fabulous content getting caught up
on the culture bench podcast i wanted to
let you know that digital advertising is
way creepier than you think i used to
sell radio and digital advertising
pre-covet in an office space style move
i'm now working for my city picking up
litter downtown all day sounds very
fulfilling
it is glorious to the point though
everything you do online i'll find
contributes to your digital advertising
profile everything you do puts you into
a category even if you're not surfing
the web every time your phone pings a
tower google gets your location
information and tailors ads based on
where you go
and more immediately where you're at
geofencing is what everyone knows about
and
thinks is the hotness uh basically it's
a digital fence around an event or
business everyone that enters that
digital fence has a cookie dropped on
their phone and then serves them the ad
the cookie them follows them uh back to
your home residence which is determined
by where you're at from 6 pm to 7
a.m each day it then send ads to your
neighbors because
the algorithms reasons uh because the
algorithm reasons that we live near
people who are like us and
are likely to have similar interests
there are literally tens of thousands of
specific advertising content categories
to get the right message to the right
person
most likely to engage with the message
and take whatever action the ad wants
you to take
i hate it yeah i i i meant to look into
this more but
there is one thing that uh so
your uh medical information is protected
by a lot called hipaa
and so like if you're a hospital
you can't sell patient records to some
advertiser
which i'm not sure is exactly what
happened but uh i remember
visiting someone in a cancer ward
and then getting targeted ads for like
different cancer centers
uh which again like maybe they were able
to like geo-target me because they know
it's there in the hospital had no
affiliation maybe because i wasn't a
patient and signed in
the the hospital sent that email there
uh but i think it's weird like i mean i
know facebook got in trouble because
they were serving ads to people based on
like their presumed hiv status which
like you know
uh that's the thing that a lot of people
like to keep private and you know if
someone's looking over your shoulder and
sees like need some hiv medication like
that's
that's not cool um if i told you
my the depression and online advertising
anecdote i've told a few times
no okay so i worked uh at a tech-ish
company
and um oh someone who worked there
had come from working for like digital
analytics and marketing someplace
and she was telling me and a colleague
who were on like the creative side of
this company
she was like um you know we can track
through someone's online behaviors if
they're considering suicide or if
they're like deeply depressed yeah
our response was oh my god well that's
great you can like reach out or give
them help and she laughed and we were
like why are you laughing she said
or they said or he said [ __ ] now someone
might know what i'm talking about but
she said
she was like oh no boys she was like
that's cute she was like we know this
because people who are considering
killing themselves are more likely to
make reckless economic purchases
so we target them for like bigger things
they might want to buy or something like
that
yeah there was a great article also
about uh like credit card data like one
easy way to tell if someone's depressed
is if they're not
leaving a certain g like if they're
staying inside all day which i know
literally everyone's doing
but if you're not leaving the house your
credit card purchases can reflect that
and your phone information can
and so like reckless economic purchases
like you're suggesting or even like hey
maybe you want like burger king
delivered to your house
um and quickly before the next email i
do want to give a shout out to
upcoming birthday boy dude abides um
1985 who's just uh just a staple
of the show uh i'm just it's his
birthday's coming up he's enjoying a
balmy sandwich today
we're always psyched to have him around
also uh cracked
pincenez uh stay beautiful everyone i
appreciate
uh being called beautiful nobody ever
does uh
that's incredible yeah uh we got any any
other emails this time around
yeah we got one last email from hobby uh
that i feel very attacked for i'm just
kidding hobby i
i really like this email um hi wisecrack
i love your podcast
i was a little behind in listening and i
just came across one when alec talks
about his love for outdoors and hiking
it's true i like those things
i guess this is random but this oddly
connects to a local issue of mine a
native of upstate new york when the
pandemic hit in governor cuomo shut the
whole state down
my small community in the catskills
buckled out and braced for the worst and
it came but not in covid
what happened instead as we all stopped
going outside residents of new york city
a giant hot spot
i should clarify at the time uh began to
use local mountains as hiking spots now
this isn't unusual but the amount we saw
was a special
especially i guess bad considering the
fact that our global pandemic was
happening and we're all supposed to stay
in our homes
frankly to my community it felt like
people from new york city ignored the
rules and traveled hours away literally
spreading the pandemic to my small town
new york city people aren't well liked
in general on the cat skills almost a
hundred percent of the locals hate them
and that situation has not getting
better as it feels like they don't care
bear in mind this influx started in
march and april during the worst part of
the pandemic hasn't only increased
i can appreciate that the great outdoors
is very therapeutic but is a health risk
to me my family and friends as
out-of-towners invade
our space this is a long way of asking
how do you balance your own mental
health with the well-being of the
community you are visiting
i am being personally called no uh this
i
i think it's really interesting because
i think i think there's like two time
frames and i should say that i literally
went upstate like a week ago and i will
explain that but i think there's like
early pandemic where new york is the hot
spot
new yorkers are doing lots of things
that are very shitty like going to other
states and spreading it to their family
members and seeing
places like florida with covid cases
because they have the money they can and
people don't think about [ __ ] and those
people are the worst
similarly like going upstate god knows
like are they wearing masks are they
stopping in gas stations are they eating
in restaurants our restaurants shut down
are they just coughing on people who
knows um and i'll say like i think the
early on people
uh i think not a lot was known and i
think i definitely
like be on the side of caution like i
don't leave my apartment for weeks at a
time
now net and then i'm juxtaposing that
with now in new york things are under
control we have like a slightly better
sense of like
safety risk and things like that if
you're wearing a mask if you're outside
it's very low risk not zero risk but low
risk
and so uh you know i'm going on more
walks i'm going upstate
and hiking i'm putting on a mask when i
see people even you know sometimes
they'll be within six feet
i feel like new york now is a very low
uh
posit has a very low positivity rate and
a very low case rate per hundred
thousand
you know i'm not uh i call me out anyone
on the internet i i feel like i'm not
adding some unique risk but at the same
time the people doing that in march and
april when we didn't know those things
or maybe we're less certain about them
those people kind of suck so i'm sorry
that
they maybe gave kova to your small town
um yeah
that sounds very relatable i get that um
i mean i know the the one time i've
traveled anywhere was technically
upstate because it was up the state of
california but i know that's not what we
call it but yeah i know when i i stayed
someplace
kind of rural and i like did all my
shopping here
when i went up i didn't really you know
i just kind of like felt like i wanted
to
honor the locals of this smaller and
less covet infected town by not going
anywhere near them yeah
and enjoying outdoor spaces alone and
not like
because i imagine the people that are
the biggest dicks are the ones that like
show up places
want to like eat out take their mask off
just be like all types of involved
rather than laying low
yeah don't be a dick if you travel yeah
and i think it was interesting because
on the trail i was like oh wow
everyone's like putting on a mask
um when they walk by me and then i look
there's like a trail registry like
everyone's from brooklyn
and sometimes people wouldn't they do
weird things like you know put their
hand over their mouth like that's not
how that works maybe it helps a little
bit
um but i mean i think the other thing is
you know uh
parks are cool and they should be for
everyone not necessarily spreading
uh the disease of covid uh everyone but
you know
uh the more people that use the trails
the better it is to maintain those
trails to get funding
yeah just be cool about it just wear
masks don't be a jerk
make other people feel safe even if you
don't need that yourself you know
uh for other outdoorsy people maybe in
other places
with i'm curious because i want to know
how to not be
that guy from brooklyn who ruins
everything
um maybe i am alec is fully that guy
from brooklyn
um so that's that's all we have for
emails right yeah that's all we have
awesome well give us give us more uh for
the next time around you have a couple
weeks to get on it once again you can
email us at culturebridge at
wisecrack.com call us at 213-534-8807
we always say this and it's not [ __ ]
we love to hear from you we love know
what's going on love to know what you
think even if it's uh negative
yeah i'm not too negative we're
sensitive humans um so before i wrap up
we will be back in a couple weeks for
you alec
if in the intervening weeks people need
your hot takes where can they find them
oh my hot takes are on wisecrack alec
there are several hot takes oh wow
um yeah you can find me at michael
o'burns on twitter i think something
similar on instagram um
if you're bored i'm doing a philosophy
book club twitch thing on fridays
uh dude abides has been showing up so i
gotta gotta have another shout out
but you can check that out i'll post a
link and stuff like that um and if
there's nothing else to be said
thank you for listening thank you for
watching if you're hanging out now and
we will catch you in a couple weeks
later guys
[Music]
you